-Hey, this is Jimmy Fallon
and this is how I start my day
♪♪♪♪
I'm lucky enough to work
in New York City,
which is the greatest city
in the world.
I love it.
And when I can,
I like to walk to work
just because you get
to see people,
you get to see store
windows and fashion.
I moved to the city in 1998 when
I got "Saturday Night Live."
The energy here
is pretty fast-paced
and it gets you going.
It's a good little jolt.
It's like having a little shot
of espresso every morning,
just going out for a walk.
Ready?
-I watch it all the time.
-Can I have your permissio
to put this online if I do
-Oh, yeah, oh, yeah.
-Thank you, buddy.
Alright, I got 18 seconds
to cross the street.
15, 14. Can I do it?
It's a pretty decent walk
from my apartment to the studio,
which is at 30 Rock
right in the middle
of Manhattan, Midtown Manhattan,
which is where I did "Saturday
Night Live" for all those years.
I'll see you
as I walk into my office. Bye.
I'm videotaping. Sorry. Sorry.
-It's alright.
♪♪♪♪
I have a COVID test at 2:30,
but my next big meeting
is 12:15,
and that's when I'll talk
to a bunch of our head writers
and producers,
and I'll talk to you then.
Okay, I just got the jokes
for the monologue.
Ready for some fun mono?
-Yeah, let's do it.
-Let's do it.
-Let's make some TV, man.
-Everyone excited
about the news
when adults who had secretly
got braces were like,
"I thought I had more time."
That's a good joke.
I would cut 1A, so we probably
need a good starter joke.
Okay, I'm getting ready
right now.
It's around 1:30 for pretape
with the Roots.
♪♪ Pretape, we're off
to a great pretape ♪♪
♪♪ Fun times ♪♪
♪♪ So count me ♪♪
♪♪ Oh, come on,
can he count me in? ♪♪
Okay, it's 2:30.
Just finished pretape.
Off to do a COVID test.
♪♪♪♪
What's the record? I can see
how many seconds it is.
I'm going to go
for two minutes straight.
It is 2:57.
I'm about to start
the monologue.
Negative results
on COVID, knock on wood.
That's great, and let's hope for
some funny jokes.
Alright, I'm going
down to rehearsal.
It is -- What's up, Keith?
It is...almost 4:00.
Come on.
[ Groans ]
There you go. Come on.
Give me that squirt, man.
Keegan-Michael Key right there
He's in there.
♪♪♪♪
He's in studio tonight,
which is awesome. We love that
Alright, we're here.
This is rehearsal.
-Hi.
-Hey!
-Whoo-hoo!
Look at that. Come on.
The lights, the bright lights.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my God, canned applause.
This is fant--
I didn't -- I didn't --
I didn't sweep over you.
I didn't --
I didn't sweep by you.
-Oh, no, don't.
-I'm not recording.
-Is James good?
-James' keyboard on?
Can you hear it?
-Yeah.
♪♪♪♪
-Okay, guys, here we go.
-Yeah. That's right -- no more
masks or social distancing
for fully vaccinated people.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Tariq, you know
what that means, bud.
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Thump ]
-Come at me, man! Come at me
[ Laughter ]
-"Come at me, man"?
Alright, 4:00.
Usually I could shower
and get ready,
but I already did a pretap
earlier today, as you saw,
so I'm just going to get dressed
in a nice suit
and get ready for the show
Alright, so, we're about
to start the show.
I'm gonna say hi to
Keegan-Michael Key,
who is awesome and he's
in studio, which is great.
Alright. Just give me
one second.
Look, this is what he's wearing.
I told him to leave the tags
-Can you get the tags off?
-No, I want to leave
the tags on.
I think that's the new thing
-You think we should just
leave the tags on?
-It is so smart.
-I don't know.
-It is so s-- Trust me.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Okay.
-We could take it out in post.
-[ Laughs ]
-We can airbrush it out in post.
In the blink of an eye,
we removed the tags.
You can't even see them.
I'm so excited for "SNL."
Oh, thank you for being here
-Yes.
-Everyone appreciates it.
Great to see you as always
Awesome. Bye.
-See ya, Jimmy.
-See ya Saturday, Jimmy.
-Yes!
Alright, now I'm getting
miked up.
Be careful, all my chest hair.
It's like a sweater
under this thing.
I'm so happy for you, Keegan
That's great.
So, I feel like he's ready
So, yeah, he's ready to go
So we go by Zog's time,
whenever he's ready.
-Give it up for Steve Higgins!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Good?
-Yeah. Perfect.
-Alright, thanks, everybody.
-Thank you. Have a good show
♪♪♪♪
-And now here he is,
Jimmy Fallon!
-Okay, that was the show.
I thought it was great.
I loved it.
Keegan was just awesome, the
guests, Zoey, just fantastic
And now I'm probably
going to give edit notes,
and then it's 6:30 now.
And then when I'm done
with that,
go home and have dinner
and then pass out
and then excited
to come back tomorrow.
Good night, everybody.